did you know that there's a 30 chance
that the dropout is streaming right now
on hulu streaming right now
yeah like it's on hulu it's on hulu
right now well then i want to get in
there and watch it even if it's just 30
so you might want to see if it's
streaming
i will are you forcing me to do it i
just think you should okay and i will
the world works in certain ways until a
new great idea comes along and changes
everything this is an inspiring step
forward you're in over your head going
to lose everything her whole image is
fake
we have to stop her do you live around
here because i live on aisle six
what's his instagram he doesn't have one
that's shady what's going on i'm gonna
tell you but you're gonna freak out it's
about giving
giving yourself over to somebody
that's love
uh just a few questions i can just save
you some time
i've had over 30 000 drinks
i don't really chew my food and i'm like
barreling towards 40. i just meant like
any pre-existing conditions
i'm a woman
world is collapsing
we need your help go somewhere else
there is nowhere else i don't think you
know what's going on out there why do
you think i'm in here are we safe here
this is what happens when you try to
take what's mine
here's to an unforgettable night
let's take beers to lanterns land like
we used to
what was that
oh
my mom queen of ruby hill did you cut
your hair yes it'll grow back
we're throwing this dinner thing you
guys should come sheila is this really
you your mother was incredibly brave or
was this like a feminist club or
something
or something you live in a strange world
yep
[Music]
my name is starkey
[Music]
you may kiss the bride
can the living marry the dead
darling where are you going
my life as a musician has taken me to a
lot of very odd places
making music has been baffling
confusing
but wonderful
it sounds like hyperbole but music saved
me
elena federova you're under arrest took
you long enough
have i got your attention
it's a new world we have to adapt making
a statement isn't enough we need to win
we're looking for something we've never
seen before
this is domino master
holy cow that was awesome
season seven let's go
oh my gosh who is it
[Music]
the staff here is incredible there is a
seven-year-old custodian who voted for
kanye teaching social studies
that's who runs the world kids
flash does have some colorful characters
you crushed it but you know it's part of
its chart
hey guys we're we're filming here
[Music]
lately i'm not where i thought i'd be
where did you think you'd be not here
while you're betraying your friends to
work for the competition this is my mess
to fix i just don't know who i am
anymore 9-1-1 what's your emergency my
wife she's dead oh my god what happened
you said you didn't take betsy home who
dropped her off her friend bam bam
[Music]
you